let's bring in south dakota's governor
christie gnome to talk about the border
good morning to you governor
good morning thanks for having me on
your show thanks for coming on beautiful
backdrop there mount rushmore i know
that um i know you went down to the
border recently you're sending your
national guard out to help impacted
states and you call this border crisis a
human tragedy why
it is i went down there to visit my
national guard i sent about 48 soldiers
down there 30 days ago we just extended
that another 30 days they are in the
most critical part of the southern
border where we see a lot of trafficking
of humans and a lot of trafficking of
drugs crossing that's impacting our
state and the entire midwest and country
besides what you guys have been talking
about all morning and that's the illegal
aliens that are coming over that border
by the tens of thousands so my guard was
perfectly suited for this mission they
also work very well with the texas
national guard and local border patrol
but they're alarmed as well as i am by
what's happening down there and how this
facilitation of in-migration is
happening by the white house sure you
were called out by dr anthony fauci
because sturgis is evidently something
he wasn't invited to uh it's a
problematic even outdoors on a
motorcycle uh you would think would be
one of the safest places to be listen to
what he said about one of the most
important events in your state
it's understandable that people want to
do the kinds of things they want to do
they want their freedom to do that but
there comes a time when you're dealing
with a public health crisis that could
involve you your family and everyone
else that something
supersedes that need to do exactly what
you want to do
governor
it's shocking to me that he continues to
pick on republican governors people who
love their freedoms and he ignores
what's happening at the border i didn't
hear him criticize president obama for
having a party at his for his birthday i
didn't hear him go after
uh the other concerts that have been
happening in this country or the
complete
um
ignoring of our federal laws by this
open border policy that president biden
has embraced dr fauci's become political
and i think it's unfortunate because
there's going to be a point in time
again here where we're really going to
need our public health officials and
know we can trust them and he has
discredited his entire profession by the
positions that he's taken during this
pandemic sure and you know it is curious
there does seem to be a double standard
you're absolutely right he talks about
surges he does not talk about the pre
the former president's big party or
lollapalooza in chicago being potential
super spreader events
and he doesn't talk about what is going
on on the southern border because you
look at the facts and apparently a week
ago today joe biden got a briefing from
his department of homeland security and
was told that about a quarter of the
people coming into the country illegally
have covent they don't test everybody
but the ones they test the quarter have
coveted which is unbelievable and
yesterday the mayor of laredo texas said
that every day because there's so many
people coming into their town they've
got to spend ten thousand dollars a day
to bust them out
and nobody is tested so people are
leaving laredo texas we don't know if
they've got covered and then they go to
austin and houston and some probably
wind up in south dakota
steve when i was down there i was just
down there for one day
we got a phone call i was with the
border patrol in my national guard they
got a phone call from a local sheriff
that said hey i've got
50 coveted positive illegal aliens here
that i'm holding at a local baseball
field what can i do with them border
patrol said i don't know what to do with
them and they said i don't know what to
do we don't have any space we're full a
non-profit that usually takes these
individuals didn't want to take them
because they were all coveted positive
and that was literally the discussion
that our border patrol officers were
having with local law enforcement there
as in they've got this crisis created by
somebody who's thousands of miles away
in washington dc and every day their
life is hell their life is held because
they're trying to make the right
decisions and they're not giving the
authorities to go forward and to really
deal with it and do the right thing so
this is a tragedy it's a public health
crisis it's a national security crisis
what this white house is doing is
they're trying to destroy america by
ignoring our laws and we know for a
nation without laws a nation without a
border that we're no nation at all and
so it's alarming to me we should be
talking about it and the hypocrisy of
how they go after and dr fauci goes
after certain individuals and not others
it's wrong and the american people need
to wake up now let's just see if he
comments because they're supposed to
have this big concert in central park in
new york city
i don't know if he wants to be critical
or not but i'd love to see him take that
on because he seems to like riots and
demonstrations
well the motorcycle bike rally is going
great we're going to have up to about a
million people here in south dakota
we always uh love it when people come
and see us in our beautiful country and
all these folks they're they're patriots
they love this country they love the
fact that they can take some personal
responsibility and go spend some time
with people that they love and so
i enjoyed going on a motorcycle ride
with them and spending time with them
having charity auctions we participated
in it's been a good week and you allow
lemonade stands there the kid who's
famous for serving the bikers lemonade
i went to see wyatt and his family and
they are it's you know i was standing
there there's lines and lines of people
waiting to donate to saint jude's uh
that this little boy had organized he
already had a dirt bike donated to him
but they are lining up and these folks
are getting off their motorcycles
handing him a hundred dollars giving him
a hug and thanking him for thinking of
other people and for raising money for
other people and so these people have
big hearts and are there supporting a
young man who's doing the right thing
let's talk governor about a young woman
by the name of tamyra mensah stock team
usa wrestler she won the gold she said
this about a week ago she said i love
representing the u.s i freaking love
living there i love it and i'm so happy
i get to represent usa she was on with
shawn last night and said this watch
my mom
raised us to be respectful and
my dad was an immigrant and he he came
from ghana he came to america and he
made a way for himself like he he had a
whole bunch of businesses and
like he he made nothing out of something
or he made something out of nothing and
i i just know that if you go out and get
what you want nothing can stop you so i
guess like just from those kind of
parents in my life
i just have love for my country she has
love for her country and unfortunately
she's the exception we didn't really
hear that many u.s athletes say i love
america
well here's the difference steve that
you're talking about is the fact that
you know she loves her country she was
raised with character integrity she has
gifts and talents she talked about her
family and that's the conversation we
need to start having in this country is
strong families that parents need to be
parents they need to spend time with
their kids if you're having problems
with your children spend time with them
make them be with you that's the people
that have time with our children are the
ones that influence them and so we have
to start talking about the problems in
this country stem from families that are
struggling and we need to start building
into them to create a stronger
environment at home so these kids can be
more successful in the future